з метою укріплення морських кордонів
нашої держави основне призначення катеру
для захисту національних інтересів у
сфері морської і військово-морської
діяльності держави на прикордонних ріках
озерах лийманах водоймищх України
зовнішніх рейдах та прибережних
акваторіях Чорного та Азовського морів з
віддаленням від Порту притулку не більше
ніж на 50
миль
[музика]
розпочинаємо церемонію спуску на воду
малого броньованого артилерійського
катеру проекту
58155 на замовлення Міністерства оборони
України
начальник управління кораблебудування
військового морських сил України Радчук
Василь Слава Україні Героям слава
шановне панство від імені командування
військово-морських сил Щиро вітаю
колектив заводу та нас Міністерство
оборони військово-морських сили з
поповненням з новим катером з доволенням
чекати Ми будемо його в Одесі на
проведення державних випробувань а також
на найшвидше входження до складу
військово-морських сил Дякуємо всім за
спільну роботу і дуже хочемо щоб це був
некрайній корабель щоб ми ще мали далі
кораблі від кузні на рибальського Слава
Україні
Дякую слово для привітання надається
секретарю Ради національної безпеки і
оборони
2014-19 років людині яка за час свого
перебування на посаді докладала чимало
зусиль для розбудови української армії і
зокрема українських військово-морських
сил Олександр
Турчинов Вітаю вас шановні друзі У нас
сьогодні дуже важлива
подія наші славетні військово-морські
сили отримують новий броньований
артилерійський
катр ви знаєте я пригадую коли ми разом
з вами спускали на воду перший
катір це Були часи
коли наша Україна могла розраховувати
виключно на
себе жодної допомоги навіть від наших
стратегічних партнерів заборона
поставляти в Україну будь-яку зброю
будь-яку техніку і тільки розрахунок на
власні сили і саме тоді ваш дружній
трудовий колектив взяв на себе
зобов'язання відновлювати Наші
військово-морські
сили це вже восьмий броньований
артилерійський катяж були випущені
десантні штурмові катери катір
розвідник і все це достатньо складних
умовах і що важливо для українського
бюджету вартість цих виробів на порядок
нижче ніж закордонних
аналогів Я хочу запитати а А як зелена
Влада чинна Влада підтримує трудовий
колектив і це
підприємство відкриваються кримінальні
справи за набдуманими політичними
звинуваченнями заграти кинутий директор
Валерій шандра бойовий генерал Ігор
Павловський також заграти за що за те що
вони чесно
працювали за те що вони робили і ставили
на озброї
військово-морські
сили вашу продукцію ваші катери які
пройшли не просто Випробування а бойові
Випробування всі ми пам'ятаємо
як катри вироблені на
рибальському Під вогнем російської
армади
проривались до керченської
протоки з одного боку криміналь справи А
з іншого боку на останньому параді
присвяченому
30тиріччю незалежності України
ваші катери гідно йшли в кільватрном
строю демонструючи силу нашої
армії друзі мої влади
змінюються президенти
змінюються уряди
змінюються а Я
переконаний
що ваш потужний трудовий колектив ваше
підприємство яке незабаром буде
слідкувати сторіччя і далі буде
випускати потрібну армії продукцію і
далі буде зміцнювати обороноздатність
нашої
країни Слава нашим словетним збройним
силам Слава вашому дожньому трудовому
колективу і слава Україні Героям
слава Дякуємо пане Олександре слово для
привітання надається генерал-лейтенанту
збройних сил України народному депутату
України девятого скликання Михайлу
забродському Слава Україні ером Слава
перш за все хочу поздоровити присутній
тут колектив славетного судьвного
предприємства і навіть ті хто не зміг
долучитися до нашого свята це дійсно
свято Кому як не нам при суутням
розуміти з якими труднощами
пов'язана судобудування
Взагалі І навіть сьогоднішній захист
спуск нави до цього проекту зокрема тут
є все і недофінансування і політична
заангажованість і кримінальні
переслідування і складності постачання
але сьогоднішній захід на мій погляд це
гідна відповідь всім тим хто сумнівався
всім тим хто намагається постановою
слідчих припинити будівництво бойових
одиниць для наших військово-морських сил
Це Крок вперед це доводить те що
колектив навіть в таких складних умовах
працював працює і буде продовжувати
працювати можна лише жаліти про те що на
сьогоднішній день в наших
військово-морських силах рахунок таких
катерів не йде на
десятки можна лише жаліти про те що з
замовленнями поки що складно але в той
же час ми всі чітко
розуміємо що якщо предприємство має
виживати і жити в таких умовах то за
умови належного відношення і належної
турботи з боку держави за умови того що
потреба в нарощуванні катерного складу
буде завжди в таких умовах предприємство
буде готове споритись з будь-яким
завданням я хотів би згадати сьогодні
про тих хто стовідсотково впевнений
дивиться нас навітьди зараз тому що для
них це справа всього життя Я веду мову
про директора Шандро і про
генерал-лейтенанта
павловського пропоную привітати їх і
поздоровити їх теж з великою перемогою
до яки вони має пряме
[оплески]
відношення шановні друзі поки держава
будує кораблі вона рахується морською
державою
Сьогодні лише черговий етап і черговий
крок щиро сподіваюсь що самим найближчим
часом ми зможемо поздоровати
військово-морські сили України з
прийняттям до бойового склада чергової
одиниці Слава Україні і вам велике
дякую відповідно до флотської традиції
пляшка шампанського розбита під час
спуску корабля на воду стає символом
довгого і безпечного плавання а жінка
обрана для цієї почесної місії стає
хрещеною матір'ю корабля і берегинею
його екіпажу це почесне право надається
яні Зінкевич народному депутату України
від партії європейська Солідарність
командиру медичного батальйону
госпітальєри секретарю комітету з питань
здоров'я
[оплески]
нації дякую мені дуже приємно сьогодні
бути тут це для мене абсолютно новий
незвичайний досвід і як тепер уже
хрещена мама цього корабля Бажаю йому
сім футів під кілим
Дякую слово надається виконуючому
обов'язки голови правління завод кузня
на рибальському Валентину
Каширському
начальнику цеха номер 500 пану шудрику
перевірити готовність катера до спуску
підготувати дорожку номер
о
спусковий тристй номер оди
[музика]
готовий розпочати
спуск
виконатийна
пусковий пристрій номер
[музика]
о тато Він
їде тато О
[музика]
w